et c'est une maman qui aime réaliser les
rêves de ces enfants qui est maintenant
avec nous pour des conseils lecture
autour d'un mot qui alors visiblement
est vraiment mis à toutes les sauces
accueille bien vieillir dites moi qui
fais me faire qu'est-ce que vous avez
sélectionné pour nous eh bien j'ai
sélectionné d'abord ce livre parce que
vous savez souvent quand on est
contrarié on commence par râler faire
partager notre mécontentement
alors j'ai trouvé ce petit livre qui
s'appelle râler ça ne fait rien avancer
de caroline pélissier virginie à la dgi
et aurore carrick
alors le jeune lecteur fait connaissance
avec nico le chacal aux yeux mi clos
il joue dans son coin solitaire pendant
que tous ses amis sont en train vous
voyez de préparer la kermesse et quand
on vient lui demander de l'aide
normalement on va dire et bien lui il va
certes mais en râlant et finit par se
fâcher avec tout le monde
et bien ce livre apparaît bien
d'expliquer aux jeunes enfants comment
éviter ce genre de situation puisqu'il
fait partie d'une série de casterman qui
s'appelle expliqué la communication
pacifistes et c'est un outil justement
de bienveillance puisque finalement le
dialogue permet d'éviter de se disputer
de se crier dessus d'être en colère
alors vous allez me dire c'est un peu
didactique comme livre mais loin des
messages subliminaux des contes de notre
enfance comme le loup du chaperon rouge
par exemple mais les enfants le
comprennent comme tels ils savent que
c'est un outil pédagogique et ils
adhèrent à partir de 4-5 ans déjà parce
qu'ils aiment bien finalement parfois se
poser et réfléchir à pourquoi il se met
en colère pourquoi ils se disputent et
comment il pourrait éviter ça donc je le
conseille les dessins sont très sympas
et c'est vraiment un outil intéressant à
partager avec qui aiment râler sur ce
plateau
moi j'aime bien percevoir mais bon si
jamais bien méchant et puis ça dure
jamais bien longtemps
en revanche on a encore un petit peu de
temps à passer avec vous allez nous
reste encore deux minutes ensemble pour
parler communication et bienveillance
qui sont les thèmes centraux de roman
parfois pour adolescents en tout cas
vous allez nous en faire découvrir
maintenant c'est véritablement là votre
coup de coeur tiphaine c'est oui mais ça
s'appelle h tendre et déjà dans le titre
on voit qu'il ya de la tendresse
c'est un roman de clémentine beauvais et
publié par sarbacane
l'idée est simple on décide de mettre en
place un service civique pour les élèves
à la fin de la 3e et pendant un an ils
doivent aller donc travailler découvrir
le monde du travail
un jeune adolescent qui s'appelle
valentin et qui est un peu timide se
retrouvent dans les hautes france à
s'occuper de personnes âgées dans une
structure expérimentale qui s'appelle
unités mnémosyne alors imaginez un
endroit où on reconstitue complètement
les années 60 70
le décor est reconstitué dans les
moindres détails mais c'est carrément un
quartier qui reconstituait à l'intérieur
pour que des personnes sénile ou qui
souffrent de la maladie d'alzheimer se
sentent bien et dans cet univers
incroyable et bien le magazine salut les
copains que vous connaissez et encore
édité et une pensionnaire participe à un
concours pour faire venir françoise
hardy problème il faut répondre à sa
lettre alors je ne vous raconte pas la
suite
mais c'est un roman vraiment
exceptionnel qui parle aussi bien de
l'adolescence que du grand âge du deuil
que de l'amour du divorce voilà c'est
très touchant en plus on a vraiment un
grand plaisir à retrouver cette période
des années 60 dans les moindres détails
je vous le conseille je conseille aux
adolescents à partir de 13 ans on va
dire et aux adultes et le style est très
intéressant puisque on oscille entre le
rapport de stage et le journal intime
c'est un vrai coup de coeur franchement
voilà c'est magnifique en plus de
prendre le temps de regarder des
personnes âgées et de les voir par le
regard d'un ado vous parlez de temps je
vais finir par râler parce que dit on en
a beaucoup tartiné mais on va faire
quand même
le tout dernier parce que j'ai noté à
propos de ce roman votre coup de coeur
achetant de j'ai noté ces porteurs de
valeurs positives
comme l'entr'aide la solidarité le
respect de l'autre et les parents que
nous sommes veulent souvent transmettre
ça à leur enfant j'ai un papa la marque
jeune papa d'elena une petite fille qui
est arrivé en même temps finalement que
votre titre de meilleur ouvrier de
france très bien finir dont on va parler
d'ici quelques minutes
je crois que transmettre à ses enfants
c'est toujours un vrai défi et pour ce
dernier ouvrage que vous nous avez
sélectionné en quelques secondes s'il
vous plaît dites moi de quoi il
s'agissait
alors le titre est limpide ça s'appelle
je transmet des valeurs positives c'est
de carla schiappa bur décès publié aux
éditions eyrolles une maison d'édition
en fait qui donnent plutôt des conseils
la parentalité ou les conseils de
bien-être et c'est une sorte de boîte à
outils en fait qui propose des activités
des outils de réflexion des conseils
pédagogiques et là vous trouverez en
fait des petites idées d'ateliers pour
transmettre vos valeurs à vos enfants
donc en trade voit la solidarité
protection de l'environnement la dépense
à quoi vous croyez
je vous le conseille c'est vraiment très
intéressant en plus l'auteur et
bourguignonnes puisqu'elle est
directrice d'école à pierre de bresse
donc voilà c'est un petit outil qui peut
vous aider à faire des petits jeux pour
transmettre vos valeurs j'aime bien en
plus elle est maman de trois enfants cet
auteur dont vous parlez la sélection
livre autour de la bienveillance à
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux et en
replay évidemment sur france 3 point fr
merci typhaine a bien combien à bientôt
bientôt